I got 100 Minecraft players and whatever
they build I'll pay for like this
thousand dollar iPhone this fifteen
thousand dollar car or even a 50 000
diamond ring server start the challenge
the color of the blocks is the budget of
their build there's a ten dollar section
A five thousand dollar section and a
fifty thousand dollar section look how
many of the people in the ten dollar
section just logged out they quit
they said I can make more money at
McDonald's I'm leaving how are the 25
000 builds coming along it's good I was
considering building Twitter because
it's probably gonna be worth less than
25 Grand oh this person's building a
really nice Pokemon card that's genius
in the fifteen thousand dollar category
what the heck hold on hold on it's been
15 minutes and this person built a whole
kitchen oh my God the buttons the
buttons yeah this person's winning a
hundred percent in this category 15
grand is on the line Jesus you really
gotta get going I've tried to build a
gaming PC you've barely built anything
so far and we're 20 minutes in
All Right contestants you now have under
30 minutes left to finish your builds
good luck you got 30 minutes left what
are you doing dude I am so bad at this
you want to know what it is what it's a
13 000 pound drum of barbecue sauce what
yeah we're buying it on Amazon right
after this in the 5 000 area there's
three gaming setups in a row this one's
definitely the best gaming setup oh this
person's building a Bitcoin that's
definitely worth 25 Grand now if we did
this a year ago the Bitcoin would be in
this category but now it's in this one
how's it going what you got going on
here is this the thing where you can
golf on the toilet yes you're a simple
man you want to be able to putt while
you poop you could get anything in the
world under 50 Grand and you want a
toilet and don't forget the Putt-Putt
and golden toilet paper don't forget
that hit the Subscribe button because
all 100 players we invited were
subscribed to this channel I'd hate for
you to miss out on the chance to win a
50 000 golden toilet because you didn't
press a free button
Pac-Man it's seven minutes I'm so
stressed out right now you're competing
for a thousand dollars and this is
actually one of the better ones I think
you've got a chance I got a chance let's
go
[Music]
all right and the building competition
is now over let's get to judging
starting in the ten dollar category the
first person to not quit built toxic
waste amazing candy I'm gonna say that
this is a good use of ten dollars up
next this person built a feastables bar
Mr B next one you can buy this many
tootsie rolls for under ten dollars
definitely more way more well I would
vote for this person except for there's
a few stores bar the winner of the ten
dollar build is this Feast was bar
because I'm biased I thought you were
Jimmy boys pick your favorite 50 build
what the heck is this is this a hamster
what do you guys rate the hamster I'm
gonna give it a 10. the eyes are so
soulless I'm gonna say seven five yeah
I'm gonna give this a five out of ten
it's not blowing me away I'm giving this
a 10 though because this I love hamster
up next this Mario thing this is a 10
out of 10 for me nine out of ten I'm
gonna give it a five because the only
Bill of half the body what Chandler
that's harsh I'll give it a two
I'll give it a five hamster and now for
the hundred dollar builds oh my gosh I
just don't think anybody did good these
are all poo poo next and now let's judge
the 500 builds up first we have a 500
monitor 500 worth of ice cream a plane
ticket I would like 500 worth of
ingredients I want to learn how to cook
they that's actually cool it's well
built this is amazing meta Quest 2 VR
headset to play Among Us with the boys
Among Us with the boys pick your
favorite build Jimmy I wanna vote for
the plane ticket but we gotta know where
it's taken him first Maestro Wait no
that's not Maestro oh not Maestro if you
win and get a plane ticket where are you
flying I'm flying to see my family in
the US I haven't seen them since covid
oh Nolan what are you ready out of 10.
10 out of 10. I want him to see his
family ten ten I think I rate it ten I'm
not gonna be the odd one now I give it a
10. you're gonna see your family
thank you boys up next we have the
thousand dollar builds a thousand dollar
laptop would not run Minecraft this
smoothly what do you guys rate this out
of ten it's got a Mac logo on it four I
give it a four five four and a half four
next Pac-Man oh they have a coin deposit
this is such a great build I give this a
eight seven out of ten four out of ten
you give it a four Jimmy's mean I give
it a eight I'm gonna I'm gonna give it
an eight it's in the lead but not for
long dude I like this telescope look he
could see Saturn with it what do you
think of this telescope this is awesome
I give this an eight I wanted to win
nine I'll give it a seven moons are cool
I wanna see it win so I'll give it an
eight why didn't you give it a ten if
you wanted to see one because it didn't
deserve it that bad all right well I'll
give it a zero then
you cost this person a freaking
telescope that's a rude all right jerk
2-1 up next is the five thousand dollar
builds it's a drum set five thousand
dollars they can be yeah shred yo what's
up guys all right give us a backstory
why do you need drums I play in a
cosplay slash anime band at this point
I've gone through about two snare drums
and for that reason
I'll give you an aid where did you get
10 give it a ten it's getting a 10 for
me I'll give it a seven I'll give it a
six dang Chandler's more of a guitar guy
I guess first place for 5K currently has
41 points that's gonna be hard to beat
guys it would probably take even like a
wedding ring oh what is this court man
what are we looking at my engagement
ring for my girlfriend of 11 years oh
wow if you won would you actually
propose her yeah absolutely I give it a
10 out of 10. Minecraft love 10 for me
all right I'll give you a 10. I'll give
you a 10 out of 10. I'm gonna give you a
10 you just want to win a ring because
of that that guy's not gonna play the
drums well I just ruined his whole
career Bryson it Bryson what are we
looking at a gaming PC does it have
nordvpn installed on it of course good
because there's a sponsor of this video
we used you to promote something Bryson
nordvpn is offering a huge discount if
you sign up for their two-year plan and
if you go to nordvbn.com you can get
four months for free isn't that crazy
that's crazy and what's even more wild
is you can use it on multiple devices at
the same time how many devices think of
a number more than that wow did you know
that nordvpn provides safety against
ransomware and fishing when you're
connected to the VPN just go to
nordvpn.com Mr Beast gaming and click
the get the deal button and Bryson
courtesy of nordvpn I'm gonna buy you
your entire gaming setup that's amazing
thank you very much now let's look at
the ten thousand dollar builds who left
when ten thousand dollars is on the line
look this person says they want a round
trip to North Carolina but I'm gonna be
honest Jimmy I don't want somebody
that's this bad at building to come to
North Carolina I agree zero zero the
next build is this ring but they forgot
the Gen them on it no the gym is Shrek's
face oh oh my God it looks good I give
it a seven I'm gonna say seven I give it
an eight I'm gonna give it a seven it's
gonna be hard to be more efficient with
ten thousand dollars I give this an
eight thirty seven that's pretty good up
next is a car a huge Jeep Wrangler for
wife they did the undercarriage real
well on this car and the Interiors made
out do care about some guy getting a
stupid Shrek ring or this guy supplying
a car for his wife you know what I'm
gonna give this a seventh I'm gonna give
the car a nine I'll give it an eight
yeah it's gonna be an eight for me dog I
hate Jeeps I'm giving it a six the Jeep
is in in the lead it's gonna be hard to
beat the Jeep
they didn't finish the watch dang they
ran out of time yeah maybe he needs the
watch
hey Lyra I moved you in here to let you
know your wife's getting a car
are you actually married I am Connie you
want to say hi hey Connie hi Connie
congrats on marrying a nerd it paid off
she's like thank God finally and now the
15 000 build this is where you start to
see the effort because real money was on
the line like this diamond that's for
some reason in a massive cave I don't
know how to buy a diamond in a cave
all right next one come over here to the
sailboat oh this is sick this is really
cool yo Nix what's up oh my goodness
hello everybody before they rate your
catamaran can you explain what it is to
them this is a small sailboat this would
be like a great day on the lake with the
boys Road a catamaran before so I'm
actually gonna give this one uh nine
I'll give this one an eight I'm gonna
give it a seven out of ten Nix you're in
the call while I rate so I'm gonna give
it an eight so you don't hate me I get
seasick so I gotta give you a four up
next we have this Charizard card that
sucks that she can see what's gonna
literally beat hers right beside her
build what is everyone Ray Charizard a
ten ten I like Pokemon eight I'm gonna
have to step in here for Knicks I'm
gonna give this six but Jimmy Pokemon
Nolan you decide whether or not she gets
a sailboat or this guy gets a Charizard
I'm gonna give it an eight oh my gosh
yeah this next one is another ring uh
Mark hello what are we looking at here
um I wanna hopefully propose to my
boyfriend so I figured I'll build all
little potential wedding venue okay I
did I'm gonna give it a seven you know
what Love's more important than Pokemon
ten uh give it a 10. this is becoming a
love Channel because I'm giving this a
listen it's the wedding ring wins once
again murka you just won you're lying
thank you oh my God you're getting
married Mark I hope you were ready I was
partially ready
next we have the 25 000 build is this
just a chest of gold Jimmy I'm gonna be
honest with twenty five thousand dollars
was lacking this dude made to Giant Tech
Deck I mean let's see what the 50 000 is
looking like we still needed a winner
for the 25k build so we gave it to this
car build and finally the 50 000 build
and the first plot is empty fifty
thousand wasn't enough I guess
everyone what do you rate the boat Jimmy
I'm gonna be honest this build is barely
better than the first one from the fifty
thousand dollars it's not winning
but this one this one I like now we're
talking Swifty all right what are we
rating we got golden toilets golden
toilet paper and the novelty golf game
set I'm in I'll give it a seven I give
it a six and a half out of ten I'm gonna
give it an eight I'm gonna say seven
well right now you're currently in the
lead let's go thank you Throne of cash
so he wants you to make him a chair out
of the fifty thousand dollars see this
one has creativity everything else was a
little you know predictable normally
normal hello explain what the heck of
Throne of cash is I was trying to think
of something that could be exact
ly a thousand dollars it's very
comfortable it has a nice cushion on it
I'll give you a seven out of ten so I'm
gonna go ahead and give it a nine eight
out of ten I want to see this exist
eight oh my gosh normally normal that
puts you in the lead this is a nail
biter all right up next is a waffle
maker do they not realize that this is
50 000 real dollars on the line
and for the last 50 000 build what is
this do they just not like money oh my
God Jimmy look at the sign it says car I
guess what do you mean you guessed
Moonlight it's for fifty thousand
dollars everyone follow me to cash man
normally normal congratulations you got
second place and one nothing what oh you
tricked me actually I tricked you twice
you did win
an idiot are you actually gonna build a
throne of money I will yes then I'm glad
you won subscribe if you haven't already
guys you can be in a video